temps l'algérie un pays qui s'ouvre à la
démocratie après les émeutes sanglantes
de l'année dernière le multipartisme est
aujourd'hui inscrite dans la
constitution
effervescence donc dans les milieux
politiques en vue d'élections mais il
semble que la véritable ligne de partage
de ce monde politique soit le pouvoir
religieux
et la jeunesse julien sont boutade de
provocation mais qui illustre les
blocages d'une société d'où les jeunes
se sentent souvent exclues les moins de
30 ans représentent les trois quarts de
la population autour d'eux depuis deux
ans le niveau de vie a baissé de 20% au
départ chute des prix du pétrole crise
économique montée du chômage
après les sanglantes émeutes d'octobre
dernier ouverture à l'idée du
multipartisme espoir et large débat dans
la rue fin de faire nos premiers pendant
la démocratie parce qu'on n'a pas eu de
tradition dans l'assaut des bacs c'est
en a débattu mais c'est comme je crois
que c'est un très grand acquis que les
événements d'octobre sa possible et le
parti des grilles peu parti les
militants et sur quatre ans les
conditions auxquelles ockrent
je suis d'accord pour le multipartisme
mais je ne suis pas d'accord du tout sur
le parti communiste
du moment qu'on est un pays musulman
seul le fln un statut légal de partie
mais les nouvelles associations
politiques sont légion comme celle du
parti social démocrate né la semaine
dernière où le rassemblement pour la
culture et la démocratie
les communistes sort petit à petit de la
clandestinité quant aux islamistes
ils viennent de doter leur nouveau front
islamique du salut d'un bureau dans
cette société où l'islam est religion
d'état
les cheikhs musulmans bénéficient d'un
réseau de militants potentiels
considérables pour l'heure leur
programme politique est enseignée dans
les mosquées en exil m ils avaient tous
les lois les politiques ne tournent tous
les chances doit bien dans l'islam
politique
donc comme c'est un vide et tout à
l'heure dans les locaux il y a tout pour
lui dire qu'il ya tous les droits
vous savez le les musulmans ils ont pas
de parti et prend le nom du parti front
islamique sauvegarde savez
pour le multipartisme mais pour les
musulmans c'est pas un parti savez les
musulmans sont tous des musulmans en
algérie
y'a pas d'autres religions lien c'est le
parti c'est le musulman c'est le retour
à la loi islamique est vécue comme une
menace par les associations de défense
des droits de l'homme et de la femme
d'où les appels à la tolérance tel celui
du docteur sadi initiateurs du
rassemblement pour la culture et la
démocratie issue du mouvement berbère
est une nécessité
et je crois qu'il aurait quelques
chances si des formations politiques
elle-même une joue je encore une fois de
manière responsable ne pas être tenté
par la surenchère un peu facile
aujourd'hui n'est-ce pas en gros
beaucoup de gens qui exige le plus que
le maximum qu'ils appellent
systématiquement à la violence ces
gens-là d'heure qu'on ne voyait pas
beaucoup il ya trois mois de stage qu'on
devrait aller
affrontez d'unicité la pression et c'est
là il nous appartient de ne rien céder
sur l'essentiel de nos convictions mais
de ne pas prendre de risques inutiles
quant à d'éventuels dérapages qui
amènerait un retour de manivelle qui
peuvent faire mal
les sports algérien et grands au moins
autant que l'incertitude car certains
évoquent en souriant cette démocratie
imposée dans quelques semaines les
députés devront statuer sur la légalité
de ces multiples associations à
caractère politique
sur quels critères on ne le sait pas
encore